Carolina barbecue is a really kind of
ancient primal way of preparing food
where you essentially are taking a whole
animal and you are cooking it very
slowly over a wood fire the recipe
couldn't not be more simple it is Pig
plus wood fire plus thyme and a little
salt it's as close as we get to that
primal scene of our proto-human
ancestors two million years ago roasting
the big animal over a fire which is a
wonderfully communal event because it
requires a lot of cooperation somebody's
got to stay up with the fire and not let
it go out someone has to prepare the
animal to be cooked
someone has to carve it and divide up
the portions and pitmasters today stand
in for the you know this lineage that
goes back probably a couple million
years and passes along the way through
the priests and Greek culture who
oversaw the the the rites the ritual
sacrifice or the or the rabbi's and in
the Old Testament who also did ritual
sacrifice there was for a very long time
the priests the butchers and the the
cooks were the same person it was a very
prestigious job there were a lot of
rules that went with it because it was
so momentous I mean meat was was very
special it was sacred and you had to
deal with the gods and we started by
actually burning the meat to a crisp as
an offering to the gods and then
somebody figured out you know they don't
really eat meat probably they really
just want the smoke and so we gave them
the smoke and that was the way you know
how else do you get it up to heaven and
then we got to eat the meat and but we
continued to have that religious overlay
and the word in Greek for priest and
butcher and cook is the same Magaro s--
and the word magic is buried in that
word the origins of the word for magic
because it was magic this transformation
of this carcass dead animal into this
food fit for the gods
you know one of the most striking things
about modern life is that we eat meat
without giving it a thought we eat meat
without realizing what is at stake the
fact that an animal has died that an
awful amount of effort is taken
there's the sacrifice of the animal
there's the effort of raising it or
killing it if you're hunting it and we
eat it without ceremony we have meat two
three times a day in this country
without giving it a thought
it's just shrink-wrap protoplasm from
the supermarket or the restaurant but
for most of history you realize eating
meat was a profound almost sacramental
occasion people understood the sacrifice
involved they understood that an animal
had died because they'd probably
participated in that process and they
also understood how precious this stuff
was it was delicious it was nutritious
you didn't have it every day you had to
work really hard to get it and so we
surrounded meat eating with a great deal
of ceremony and somberness and rules you
know the proper accompaniment for meat
in world history if you look at it
appears to be rules whether the kosher
rules that you eat this meat and not
that or you eat this part of this animal
and not that part or you don't have meat
with this or that halal rules also
govern meat what can and cannot be eaten
but then you have the rules of barbecue
in some parts of the south barbecue is
whole hog with just vinegar and salt and
you know a little pepper but you move to
the other side of the same state and
they have a ketchup base sauce and they
cook pork shoulders and then you move to
South Carolina and they're there
barbecuing pork shoulders and they're
using a mustard based sauce and then you
go to Tennessee and they're eating ribs
and you go to Texas and they're eating
brisket they're eating beef every one of
those traditions has deep roots and
every one of those traditions looks down
on every other tradition as that's fine
but it's not barbecue so rulemaking
seems to surround meat-eating and and I
think that that's a reflection of how
much was at stake for people and how
wonderful it was for people and we have
lost that we meet in this incredibly
thoughtless
Cavalier Way we waste it we don't give a
thought to the animal we don't give a
thought to the person who raised it or
hunted it and I think in the process
we've lost something and that
carelessness it now infects the way we
raise the meat that we treat the animals
really badly and we don't we don't honor
it the way we need to honor